[Music]
do you think Jordan comes back if Go Go
if the Bulls win the finals without him
yes I think he comes back and I would
love to see that alternate history
because I don't think he goes to the
Bulls yeah same thing I want to see how
I there's it open it you let's pull back
so let's pull back right so so Jordan
leaves a sport the next year they go to
the Eastern Conference Finals they are
one game away I think was the conference
semi-finals but they went to game 7 and
then the Knicks beat the Pacers in the
Conference Finals and then what no they
went to the Eastern Conference Finals he
double-checked that mark yet they lost
in the semis when Jordan came back but
they went to the Eastern Conference
Finals when the first year at that night
and they lost to the Knicks I know they
lost in seven I thought it said either
way that's the team that made it to the
finals yeah you lost a team you don't
steal they made the finals right and so
they go to ease and commerce finals
without him they loosen the Knicks uh I
don't think Jordan is rooting for that
Bulls team no chance
[Music]
because if they win without him they
don't eat him now they do not need him
it tarnishes everything he's worked for
oh yeah he wants to be in the same
league as magic and Burt that's what
he's been saying since the beginning
magic and Burt's teams don't just go win
without magic and bird no chance not
even a [ __ ] chance no chance right
LeBron leaves his team when he was with
the laws apart it falls apart so I see
you think it's like a KD situation which
is like Katie got his rings of the
Warriors but we don't give him as much
credit because they're not his Rick it
would be that because they they can win
without him it's exactly it would be a
[ __ ] in a ring without you I don't know
impressed so that first year they don't
win he's like woof the second year that
he's not on the team yet the year he
ends up coming back they struggle they
are yeah they're not doing great and
that's what I think brings him back is
he's like I get to be the Wild West here
oh yeah I get to save the day
oh they're barely making it into the
playoffs well I can't be able to play
baseball because of the strike [ __ ]
should I come back and save the day
do do I think even a doper question is
does he come back if that strike didn't
happen in baseball here's what I think
could happen he's slowly this ain't
getting better and better
let's get into the baseball thing in a
second because I want to talk about I
won't tell him in a second but but if
the Bulls end up winning without him
where do you think what do you think I
think he goes to another team I prove I
can beat the Bulls and he probably go to
an Eastern Conference team where as a
lot of like Tom Brady as much as I think
he's a goat he went to the a of the NFC
to get away from Bill Belichick I think
Michael would go to the east just to
make sure he faces the Bulls oh I think
Brady went there so he could face
Belichick in the [ __ ] oh that's the
that's a super elf I think he's thinking
I hope I don't have to face him up
because I
you can also I'm gonna make sure I play
you I can go to the AC I go the [ __ ]
dolphins play twice a year
mmm [ __ ] you you know I think he could
have gone where the Knicks and he loved
playing at the Garden Isle playing at
the garden you're in a huge market they
were to worship Him he would have
finally got them the ring they hadn't
had in 20 years of that boy whenever
Patrick would've been a great number two
amazing [ __ ] you Scottie Pippen go for
the league or have but that's as we're
talking it out that makes a ton of sense
to me okay Jordan at the Garden every
night that'd be perfect
okay so then he decides to go play
baseball there's a strike he stops
playing baseball will rewind a little
bit if Jordan if there's no strike
is there even a shadow of a doubt at any
of your heads that Jordan makes the
majors as a baseball player yeah a
little bit but I can I don't know
anything about baseball and I feel like
Jordan played a real sport at a high
level so we could probably baseball a
hundred percent I really gently released
the majors I truly believe that there is
in Jordan's prime there is not a single
physical activity that he could not do
at a professional level given the amount
of time he would need to train I think
if you wanted he would be the best
swimmer despite you know
I think if you want he would be the best
skier I think if you want he would be
the best at whatever he chose to do and
I think it just comes down to god-given
physical talent and god-given work ethic
and the work ethic is actually a thing
that's more impressive to me because
usually when you have that much physical
talent you're lazy because you can be in
and he had the work ethic of a [ __ ] of
Muggsy Bogues he had the work ethic of
the smallest guy in the NBA with the
most perfect basketball body that we've
ever seen you put that into baseball I
swear to God give Jordan two more years
you see him in the majors yeah